clear your mind
let yourself fall away
[Music]
when you fall away you gotta trust
that somebody gonna get you you know how
you go to those
seminars where you fall the [ __ ] away
and then catch your ass
eight nine people catch your ass
you trust [ __ ] not to drop you
but you don't know these [ __ ]
you don't know what them you don't know
if this [ __ ] got
weak ass hands and they're gonna drop
you in your [ __ ] head and then
you're gonna be
in the [ __ ] emergency room and [ __ ]
driving around the [ __ ] ambulance
you know what the [ __ ] happened these
[ __ ]
drop me [ __ ] drop me
[Music]
well you can trust me fall away
breathe in breathe out
center yourself try to get centered
center yourself steady yourself
keep breathing in through your nose
out through your ass
keep doing that i'm gonna go and grab me
a [ __ ] snack
i'm in a tapioca move today you know
tapioca
your grandma makes that [ __ ] for you
[ __ ] tapioca
see i just took you somewhere and your
[ __ ] mouth was watering
for some [ __ ] tapioca and who doesn't
like tapioca
you